It
frustrated by his success in the day,
or at least the excuse she
jumped,
right?
It's not a casual,
aggressive,
impulsive.
When twist your hand is in your hands because it wrangler and you see crowd
people,
it's not bad.
It's very,
very deliberate.
And to hit people one continuous sequence like that.
And then I talked to a journalist who had seen his hand the next day he was
raised in court.
She said that he walked into the courtroom like someone who's near Fort Ward.
And so,
so there's this constellation of action.
I think the only proper way to describe those options as evil action.
That is in some sense,
because you described the options as equal as to also simultaneously proclaim
the reality of good and evil in the world.
But that doesn't really bother me because I can't see that presenting
alternative language.
It's useful to describe.
You might not agree with that
you might want to make,
but that's the appropriate language within which to close such event.
I need to be appropriate language.
And that means that in order to understand that you have to speak a language of
good and evil,
and I do believe this to be true.
I can tell you why in part one of the things that's happened to me,
I didn't lecture online a distinction between tried to do an eval and I think
it's one of the most effective but direct delivered are starting to say brigade
out conceptually earthquakes and cancer,
you know standard catastrophes of life.
The perpetrator acts of God will speak very hard on the people obviously and how
often did Jay from the level of tax which are getting in the same manner and you
might think therefore the same,
they're not the same thing.
They're tragic use.
One thing and the level of this is another thing and the level of tragedies,
the worst things that we actually don't this as clinicians if we're awake like
all of those because one of the things that it's well documented in the clinical
literature is what causes post traumatic stress disorder.
Generally speaking,
it isn't exposure to tragedy opposed to disorder can usually what causes post
traumatic stress is exposure.
To my level.
So not only can you have to be hurt or do you have to be hurt by someone who is
intended for food.
That's why I'm very,
the other variants of this often happens to soldiers.
They go into battle and they observe themselves something that's deeply 11th,
and they never knew that.
They had to ask him for that.
Perhaps just part of them that even enjoys it,
at least in the vulnerable thing.
And afterwards they're fragmented by the consequences.
Say people who were perhaps somewhat too naive,
he can make effective soldiers.
Um,
they observe themselves doing something terrible on the battlefield and then
they're broken and they cannot be prepared.
And I've had many heart,
it's very difficult for them to be repaired.
And I've had many people like that contact me and say that because they've
watched the select trouble,
the distinction between tragedy and evil,
they have been able to recover,
at least in part from the post traumatic stress disorder.
And so in my own clinical practice when I treated people,
I had a client who was a young woman and she had been bullied very badly by a
boy who she did not want to go up with it.
After that made it his life's work to bring her down.
When she did very effectively is friends and they pulled her into a state of
absolute psychosis.
When I first saw her,
she couldn't even speak and she was hallucinating.
She had arbitrary and visual hallucinations and I could barely communicate with
her.
I spent about eight months with her slowly detailing out what happened and what
could really affected her was the fact that she couldn't understand how anyone
can be so cruel as to bloat with the way to do nothing but make her life
miserable and that's what broke her and she was real.
It was really serious and we had to sit and talk.
First of all,
I tried to carry weight and then as she recovered in increasingly coherent ways
about good and evil,
essentially about the fact that people can be motivated to pursue nothing.
That disruption and pain and misery and to do that consciously and within 10
accidentally and assets as the victims of some of the process,
you know,
but fuck,
knowing full well what they're doing it and doing it because they know what
they're doing.
And she was a lot more mature,
let's say at the end of that process that she was at the beginning,
uncle,
she paid great crisis Chrysler for politics,
which is typically the case.
So I do understand that.
I do understand what sort of language is necessary for use to frame these sorts
of situations.
And uh,
and I think the language of good and evil is the appropriate language.
You aren't treating the topic we sufficient seriousness unless you need the
appropriate terminology and evil.
To me,
it's something like the generation of harm for the sake of the harm.
It's best to think about it as a continent,
this fed.
And you can understand that if you think about the assignment of mentioned work
will set you free.
There's in this
dramatic or artistic statement painted block essentially.
And people don't like that idea because we don't like definitely,
you know,
we like to think that the only cause of human
inappropriate human action is increments.
Like people just do better.
They wouldn't do it.
And it's like I'm afraid that just doesn't cut it.
People know perfectly well what they're doing and that's exactly why they're
doing it.
I mean,
there's increments evolve.
What does eight parents involved in everything and it's,
it's not sufficient explanation.